سوف تكون رده فعلنا متناسبه مع هذا
العدوان لان الحديث الان عن وجود دولتنا
انهم لا يستطيعوا ان يفكر انه من المستحيل
ان ينتصر ضد الروسيا على ارض المعركه لذلك
سوف يستخدم ضدنا حرب المعلومات وسوف
يوجهون هذه الضربات ضد الشباب والاجيال
الشابه وبالطبع يستخدم الكذب بشكل مستمر
ويدورون التاريخ ولا يتوقفون عن الهجم ضد
الهجمات ضد ثقافتنا وديننا الارثوذكسي
انظروا ماذا ماذا يفعلون مع شعبهم
يدمرون الاسره والوحده الثقافيه
ليحاول ان يحاولوا الاطفال لشذوذ حتى يصبح
هذا
شيء طبيعي في حياتهم اما رجال الدين
يجبرونهم ان يوقعوا على عقود قران
مثليه
الشعب لديه حق ان يعيش وكل شخص لديه حق ان
يعيش كما يريد نحن قلنا هذا وفي روسيا نحن
لا نتدخل في الحياه الخاصه ولا احد يريد
ان يقوم بهذا ولكن اريد ان اقول لهم
انظروا اسمحوا لي ان اقول هذا انظروا
للكتب المقدسه في جميع الديانات القديمه
كل شيء هناك كتب قالوا ان الاسره هو اتحاد
بين رجل وامراه
وحتى هذه النصوص المقدسه الان توضع تحت
الشك كما تعلمون ان الكنيسه الانجليزيه
تخطط
ان تنظر الى الراديو بن ذو جنس حيادي
اعذرني يا رب انهم لا يعلمون ماذا يفعلون
مليون الملايين من البشر في الغرب يفهمون
جيدا انهم يقودونهم الى كارثه انسانيه لكن
النخبه يجنون
واعتقد ان هذا الجنون لا علاج له ولكن هذه
مشكلتهم هم اما نحن علينا ان ندافع عن
اطفالنا وسوف نقوم بهذا سوف ندافع عن
ابنائنا ضد هذا الانحطاط